In a world of 7 billion people
who is most typical?
The world's most typical person
Is right handed
Makes less than $12,000 a year
Has a cell phone
But not a bank account.
Less than 25% of us do
So what does he look like?
The world's most typical person is male
Males outnumber females
but just barely
The median age of the world's population is 28
The largest ethnic group is Han Chinese
Based on these traits
the world's most typical person is
a 28-year-old Han Chinese man
There are over 9,000,000 of them
Researchers averaged 190,00
of their photos
to create a composite image
This is the world's most typical person
But he won't be typical for long
By 2030 that person will come from India
And typical is always relative
The typical man in Holland is 5' 11"
The typical man in Peru is 5' 4 1/2"
In Japan, the typical woman lives nearly 86 years
In Afghanistan, she lives 45 years
The typical American uses 100 gallons of water
at home per day
In parts of Ethiopia, it's 2.5 gallons
And some women spend 8 hours/day collecting it
Typical people have choices to make
But they're not the same for everyone
And our choices make a big difference
When multiplied by 7 billion
7 billion - The surprising face of the most typical human
A year-long series on global population in National Geographic Magazine